i
[Música]
recuerdo la primera vez que abrir los
ojos a la pasión de mi vida tenía 13
años y fue cuando presenciar el cambio
imagen de julia una mujer que luchaba
contra el cáncer de mama como parte de
un programa de la organización en la que
trabajaba mi mamá durante el proceso y
vi cómo fue cambiando su actitud con la
ropa el peinado el maquillaje se podía
notar en su energía que aumentaba y en
su mirada que la hacía brillar aunque yo
era una niña y una simple espectadora en
mí se quedó grabado ese momento y
descubrí el poder de la imagen en las
emociones de las personas conforme
pasaron los años me fui envolviendo en
todos los programas de televisión sobre
moda y crecía en mí una necesidad por
conocer más sobre el tema y ver el
impacto que tiene en nuestras vidas
quería crear e innovar para que la moda
y la apariencia lograran un impacto más
grande que solamente vestir a alguien
quería cambiar vidas de manera
significativa y es por eso que puse toda
esta pasión en estudiar diseño de modas
para mí la moda es un espacio donde
puedes reflexionar sobre problemáticas
sociales reales
en el 2030 podría duplicarse a 3.2
millones de mujeres diagnosticadas en
todo el mundo con cáncer de mama siendo
en méxico uno de los principales muertes
es impactante ver estas realidades y no
abrir los ojos una vez más por esto en
la parte final de mi carrera creamos a
lea una línea le sería especializada
para mujeres sobrevivientes de cáncer de
mama como proyecto de tesis junto con mi
equipo queríamos crear los mejores
diseños pero con esto nos enfrentamos a
unas realidades que están fuera de la
nuestra
está lencería ya existe pero como muchas
otras cosas en la industria y en el
mundo solamente cubre las necesidades
básicas que es ser un brasier imagínate
tener 32 años y usar esto a diario
queríamos cambiar la experiencia que
tienen al comprar este tipo de lencería
porque se vende en tiendas ortopédicas
junto a sillas de ruedas junto a pelucas
oncológicas en hospitales y en farmacias
no entendíamos korea la necesidad de
recordarte algo que ya habías vencido
es algo tan íntimo y exponerlo de esta
manera durante el proceso de
investigación con 20 mujeres que pasaron
por mastectomías nos dieron una
retroalimentación de lo que lo que
podríamos cubrir nos encontramos con que
con cortes diseño y vimos que podíamos
cubrir muchas necesidades para para
dejar atrás todo esto que estaban
viviendo nuestro objetivo principal era
que se sintieran incluidas en la
sociedad y dejar atrás toda la
experiencia que tuvieron
en nuestra sesión de fotos ya con la
línea lista mari fue nuestra modelo es
una mujer sobreviviente de cáncer de
mama con una mastectomía parcial y una
reconstrucción como le quisimos dar toda
la experiencia de ser una modelo y
sentirse hermosa hicimos una
colaboración con un salón de belleza y
durante el proceso del maquillaje y el
peinado y todo y todo lo que lo que
basaba en que se sintiera mejor
personalmente me remonto a mis 13 años
y vi como como todo eso toda esa imagen
que tuve a esa edad estaba haciendo
realidad otra vez que yo era un motivo y
nuestro proyecto era un motivo para que
alguien se sintiera otra vez mejor
durante el proceso de la sesión de fotos
vimos como fue dejando atrás toda esa
lucha de dolor de desesperación y la
cambiamos por sensualidad por seguridad
pero sobre todas las cosas
vimos una felicidad única en ella una
sensualidad envidiable todos los retos
que pasamos para llegar a este momento
realmente habían valido la pena también
nos dimos cuenta que las mujeres tenemos
muy poca educación sobre nuestro cuerpo
no nos vamos a hacer un chequeo lo
dejamos pasar también un tabú
impresionante sobre la enfermedad del
cáncer y más sobre la lencería alea fue
un proyecto que personalmente me cambió
la perspectiva de vida de lo valiosa y
cambiante que es el poco valor que le
damos a cosas de uso tan cotidiano como
es para nosotros las mujeres un brasier
el cineasta mexicano alejandro gonzález
iñárritu dijo si en algún momento dado
tu obra tu trabajo cambia o inspira a
alguien a hacer algo mejor
[Música]
estas palabras fueron para mí
un aprendizaje enorme el pasado 19 de
septiembre en el temblor de mexico como
muchos de ustedes yo lo vi a través de
las redes sociales sentí una impotencia
y un miedo pero más porque no sabía cómo
podía ayudar y aportar algo masivo a las
horas que pasó esto se compartió que la
diseñadora mexicana lección y barry
adaptó unos chalecos con leds y así
ayudó a los rescatistas para mí como
diseñadora me llenó de orgullo ver que
la moda o el diseño de modas está
aportando de manera significativa a la
tragedia
sentí una impotencia y una necesidad de
ayudar más grande
que nunca eran las 3 de la mañana y vi
uno de los vídeos y se me partió el alma
llegué a mi casa a dormir y vi el techo
y dije cuántas personas en este momento
tienen el techo encima y eso es la
reflexión que tuve a las 4 de la mañana
cambió la perspectiva de todo lo que
sucedía en ese momento me paré a la cama
y casualmente me dijo un mensaje un
amigo diciéndome que nosotros teníamos
toda la universidad para aportar a la
idea de lección lo compartimos en redes
sociales y a las horas en una parte de
la universidad se empezaron a juntar
alumnos
para cortar y coser y adaptar los
chalecos hicimos unos chalecos adaptados
con dos partes dos bolsas de red en la
parte frontal con luces leds que
compramos en una tienda de materiales y
por la parte de atrás de una manera más
sentimental
quisimos recordarles el emblema del
momento que era fuerza mexico pero para
eso necesitábamos más manos más dinero y
más apoyo
por eso los maestros y padres
personas de la universidad nos empezaron
a apoyar se separaron todas las clases
todo el mundo empezó a para tronar a
coser había gente que no sabía hacer
nada de eso y llegaba con toda la
iniciativa de ayudar
y se volvió toda una iniciativa masiva
que a los pocos momentos llegaron los
medios de comunicación y estaban
cubriendo una nota que el nuevo león fue
un impacto la verdad personalmente yo no
entendía que estaba pasando porque había
tanto movimiento pero era enrique
enriquecedor ver cómo la comunidad socia
una comunidad en sí sin ver a quien se
estaba ayudando también les quiero
presentar a troy es parte de nuestro
equipo de seguridad de la universidad
que fue nuestro modelo para patronal y
diseñar las botas para los perros
rescatistas marque a bloggers a
youtubers pedir apoyo en tablet una
línea de comunicación con una persona de
de ciudad de méxico que vi el número por
facebook y nos estaban pidiendo apoyo
para gol para botas y chalecos y les
hicimos llegar ellos son las personas
que lo mandaron y que lo recibieron
logramos
[Música]
el sábado a las 8 de la mañana tiemblo
dos veces seguidas en oaxaca
yo estaba en el taller sola y ya tenía
un camión destinado a oaxaca a las 12
del día y no teníamos chalecos y estaba
sola mandó un mensaje porque no podía
con la impotencia de ver que teníamos la
posibilidad de aportar otra vez ya los
10-15 minutos el taller se volvió a
llenar de alumnos maestros y logramos
mandar 5 t2 chalecos de forma inmediata
a oaxaca en su totalidad logramos
adaptar y enviar 182 chalecos a la
ciudad de oaxaca chiapas puebla morelos
y 52 botas para perros rescatistas
demostramos que el diseño cuando se va
de una manera en un proyecto o una
manera social puede lograr muchas cosas
unir vidas cambiarlas y porque no
queremos creer que con todo este apoyo y
todo nuestro esfuerzo ayudamos a salvar
algunas
muchas veces no nos damos cuenta del
poder de nuestras acciones en la vida de
alguien más hace unos años me invitaron
a unirme a una organización que se llama
fashion revolution que se dedica a
concientizar a las personas sobre el
consumo de ropa por esta organización
que tiene dos preguntas claves quién
hizo tu ropa y bajo qué condiciones
ella es una niña de 10 años que vive en
eeuu creen que debería de trabajar a
esta edad
ella tiene la misma edad y es de
bangladesh y es una de las millones de
niños que trabajan bajo la industria de
la moda 16 horas diarias bajo
condiciones deplorables después de ver
estas situaciones me metí a mi closet vi
la cantidad de ropa que tenía y me
cuestioné si realmente es necesaria la
manera en la que consumimos porque
aunque yo estoy metida en la industria
no tenía ni idea quién había producido
esa ropa de que textiles eran y de qué
manera yo estaba afectando a otras
personas y más al mundo porque aunque lo
queramos dejar por un lado la industria
de la moda de la moda es una de las
principales contaminantes en el mundo
yo creo que hay muchas cosas que no
podemos cambiar y que no están en
nuestras manos como lo es una enfermedad
como el cáncer o un terremoto pero hay
muchas otras que tenemos en nuestras
manos la posibilidad de transformarlas
seamos la generación que hace algo al
respecto abriendo los ojos cuando vemos
la realidad de frente
hagamos realmente un cambio
muchos dicen que cambiamos el mundo yo
sí creo en esa posibilidad pero
empecemos por cambiar nuestro mundo con
el simple hecho de estar conscientes de
que vestimos
dejemos atrás la idea de la banalidad de
los estereotipos y hagamos realidad el
cambio y el apoyo a través de lo que
vestimos hagamos de la moda una
revolución gracias
[Aplausos]